democrats across the country getting
ready to dish out some cold hard
cash with no strings attached several
cities rolling out universal
basic income programs where people can
get up to
a thousand dollars a month for doing
nothing
the idea gaining momentum in major
cities like new york and los angeles
and chicago dagon what's wrong with that
well this is such a brilliant idea at a
time when businesses that are trying to
reopen and get back on their feet
can't find enough workers there's a
worker shortage in part because of the
stimulus checks that have been sent out
in the last year and the extra
unemployment benefits that are still
being paid
and you see it far and wide businesses
truck drivers and
as entry-level low-wage and skilled
workers even
child care information technology one
restaurant
i've heard about was offering a thousand
bucks if workers stayed on the job for
90 days so it creates an incentive
at the local level for people not to go
out there almost seven and a half
million job openings but
that's higher than before the pandemic
even started
allow me to quote dana perino there is
honor and
dignity in work
and it's a fantastic point considering
the statistics that are out there jesse
i'm sure you've seen it as well there
are companies all across america
that are saying we've got thousands of
job openings but we can't
fill them there's often times multiple
reasons for that but one
common denominator is they say some
people are doing
better off staying home than they are
leaving the house to go to work
a degen's right and this will also
increase illegal immigration
no one's going to do those low-wage jobs
they'll just pour across the border and
they'll start taking those jobs and
not paying taxes and then wire the money
back home
i don't know the democrats might have
just figured it out
just bribe people to vote for him i i
see that
why stop at a thousand let's go to two
into three until
you could just overload the treasury and
no one knows what's going to happen
we'll just print it
that's what we do right now i just see
every homeless person or
someone down on their luck or drug
abuser they'll just move to la
chicago new york get a mailbox address
collect a thousand dollars a month why
not why not i just don't think that's a
great way to run a city
one is that what this is about buying
votes
you're talking to me i i this is nothing
to do
i mean i just listen to this stuff and i
just laugh because i mean now all of a
sudden
illegal immigrants are voting i i don't
know what to make of this
to my mind now this is a
i think you said people were just going
to cross the border to get this benefit
and they're going to vote i
i just think it's nuts i'd say they'd
get the benefit checks
and then they'd wire it home they do it
they wouldn't get but they're not going
to get any benefit they're not citizens
jesse so i mean but i understand
okay you just want to put this guy it's
not widespread
this was i said that andrew yang
remember please okay remember andrew
yang during the
democratic primaries uh he had this idea
universal basic income a lot of people
have this idea i've discussed this with
greg about
with increased automation in the job
place they're more
need and more discussion about whether
this is
a good idea and by the way much of this
idea comes from
conservative thinkers president nixon
had had it way back milton friedman
thought it was a better idea
to give people money directly do away
with the whole welfare bureaucracy
mitt romney had an idea again this is
not for everyone but for very poor
people
or pregnant women trying to keep them
from going into
sort of catastrophic straights that's
what this is about
i don't know why you want to paint this
as some giveaway to bums
it's universal basic income that's
convinced me
universal basic income and don't stop
there right bernie sanders greg is
talking about free college tuition for
all as well yeah you know
i'd like to cite a brand new uh fox
opinion poll
uh 98 favor free stuff
two percent were dead so this is an
eternal truth nothing is ever free
uh you know the the key variable when
you know you've entered
adulthood is when you understand
cost-benefit analysis
nothing is ever free the cost is
felt somewhere however i'm always open
to stuff like this
as long as you can measure it and you
can experiment
in a finite space like how do you
measure the effectiveness of ubi
is it in crime stats is it in
homelessness
is it mental illness i don't know how
you measure the benefits and
i think what jesse's point was making is
you can't have an open border and free
stuff at the same time because you're
going to bankrupt
you're going to bankrupt the city so
that's that i think that is a big
problem but i just
i don't know i would like to i would
like to see something like this
but i think that what you know what's
behind this story
fear in silicon valley as the wealth
concentrates into a very uh very small
number of super billionaires
and then trillionaires they are going to
be worried
about the ma the the the rank and file
you'll pay off the peasants
yeah you got to pay off the peasants
because they're going to come with the
pitchforks
on bart no less all right we're going to
leave it there